wake up in the morning
don't see yourself the same
[Music]
ain't got no motivation
and your eyes are dried out
from crying all night
cause he left you there
when it didn't win twice
in the mirror
you don't like what you see
I got some monster space
and barely no self-esteem sometimes
[Music]
you weren't even here
and they blame yourself
[Music]
never win
you don't know who to turn to you don't
know where to go
there's one thing I know is true
[Applause]
[Music]
you're walking through alive now don't
see the world the same
no directions
nothing means anything to you
and your heart is heavy
and you don't see no way out Times Are
Gonna Change
[Music]
[Applause]
it's gonna be all right
[Music]
I do believe
it's gonna be all right it's gonna be
all right playing on something Mr Rob
Thomas
[Music]
you ain't got no best friends
there's one thing I know is true
[Music]
there's gonna be all right it's gonna be
all right
[Music]
it's gonna be all right
[Applause]